More women die
giving birth in the US than in any other industrialized country,
which means that, like,
having sex with a man,
if you're an American woman in 2024,
is one of the most dangerous things that you can do.
In a world where access to birth control is being threatened
or women are being criminalized for doing IVF,
where our period apps are being tracked and surveiled,
and that even if we have a miscarriage,
can be used against us
as grants for suspicion that we had an abortion,
why would women risk it?
Like, increasingly, women are not.
they're not gonna get more babies out of us.
And consistently voting against fraternity leave and maternity leave
and paid leave,
universal childcare, will mean that women have more babies with men.
It'll mean that they might start avoiding them.